[Music]
hey what is up guys of kabhi HD here and
this phone this Galaxy Note 8 this is
the best phone Samsung makes right now
I'll go ahead and say that right off the
bat it's also the most expensive phone
samsung made so last year's Note 7 kind
of went onto the radar because of the
sales stopping and obviously everything
that happened to it but it was low-key
one of my favorite phones of last year
before all that sort of blew up oh wow
that's a that's a bad joke but Galaxy
Note 8 is again trying to be one of
those phones that checks all the boxes
and that is a great smart phone this is
clearly Samsung's attempt at making
their best smartphone possible it's
swinging for the fences it's trying to
hit a homerun so let's treat it like
that and let's see if you should buy one
or not let's break it down so if you
recall some of my previous reviews I've
had about five pillars of a great
smartphone those five and if a phone
does all those five things well then
it's probably worth the money seems like
a complete package I'll give you the
green light to buy it
recommendation is go Galaxy Note 8 does
four of those five things really well
like not just good but great but then
kind of fall short on the last thing but
then it kind of makes it up its own
sixth category with a bunch of extra
stuff that it kind of throws in there
and doesn't have to nail this category
it's not part of the essential five
pillars I don't think but it kind of is
why people would end up buying this
phone it's what makes the note the note
so Samsung's build quality has been on
point for a while now this is a
refinement of last year which is a
refinement of the year before that and
the year before that but you can see the
display melts over the edges of the
sides and gets pretty damn close to the
top and bottom bezels it's not bezel
this but I'd say that 83% screen to body
ratio is very 2017 and it's super
refined versus previous years like I
said so the edges aren't sharp anymore
it has this overall boxy shape but
there's still an aluminum rail to hold
there's no camera bump or protrusion at
all on the back so it doesn't rock on a
table and I honestly think Samsung has
had the best industrial design in
smartphones in the past two or three
years and the note is no exception to
that rule I mean they kind of played a
part in making this glass sandwich
design more popular in today's world of
smartphones we see it everywhere now
which some people don't like because of
fingerprints maybe or possibly dropping
it maybe being more breakable but even
those two things could be easily fixable
with some
like a deep branch skin and that has
zero effect on wireless charging the
worst part about it I'd say is the
fingerprint reader placement it's way up
high next to the camera and on this
really big phone it means there's
absolutely no natural way to hold the
phone while using it and be able to
reach this fingerprint it requires a
like a hand shuffle to reach it it's not
a huge issue because you don't have to
use a fingerprint scanner but I prefer
for the record a fingerprint reader in
the middle of the back of the phone so
yeah for this badass looking super
sturdy metal and glass premium fully
water sealed like edge to edge display
beautiful when clean type of look Galaxy
Note 8 definitely checks that box and
then the display it's also the single
best display in any smartphone again
somehow they keep getting better at this
this time it's a six point three inch 20
960 by 1440 Super AMOLED display and
it's gorgeous
in all conditions I sent us a couple
months ago galaxy s 8 and galaxy s 8
plus had the best display now note it's
panel is the same resolution but bigger
and brighter 1200 nits now versus a
thousand and there's pretty much
perfectly viewable outdoors which really
matters when navigating or in a car or
something and of course since it's an
OLED colors are awesome
blacks are pitch black contrast ratios
are incredible it's super sharp it's
even HDR 10 compliant and it still keeps
the pressure sensitive home button at
the bottom of the glass on top of all of
that side note I still think this
implementation is best we're probably
gonna see a lot more edge to edge
displays and phones this year and you
kind of wonder what you do with the home
button we used to see on every
smartphone I think until we see that
fingerprint reader under the glass this
sort of pressure sensitive area to go
home whenever you want is the way that
we should do it but I think the bottom
line here is in the display Department
Galaxy Note 8 also checks that box and
then the camera on the note 8 is still
one of the best in any smartphone again
it's rocking a 12 megapixel F 1.7
primary camera and an additional 12
megapixel camera with an F 2.4 telephoto
lens and this time both have optical
image stabilization making it the first
phone to do that and the quality is
about what you'd expect from Samsung
it's the same characteristics you've
kind of seen by now just a little extra
saturation in the colors a little extra
sharpening from corn
to corner it's like a little bit less
realistic but a little bit prettier than
real life and I'm continually impressed
at how well these things handle the more
extreme colors and high dynamic range
seriously very few cameras handle Reds
this well in this shot the Sun is
actually right behind the hotel but you
can see the detail still in the clouds
in the sky and in most outdoor shots you
can count on getting detail both in the
lightest and darkest parts of the
exposure even this backlit shot looks
totally fine and it's safe to bring this
thing into low light of course as well
obviously being optically stabilized and
letting in a ton of light helps out a
lot with that so there's a lot of good
things happening with the camera puts it
firmly in confident point shoot
territory meaning if you see a subject
that you just want to take a picture of
just a double top of the home button
point and shoot and you'll probably get
a good shot so that second lens they
added for that telephoto zoom I found it
kind of hit or miss actually it's not as
good as the main camera and I can
actually tell the difference in quality
with the 1x vs. 2x photos so sometimes I
actually didn't want to use it as much I
would rather take a photo with the main
camera and zoom in a bit later which
kind of defeats the purpose but so one
thing it did sometimes really work well
with was live photos which is their
version of the portrait mode we've seen
coming to so many smartphones lately so
with the note 8 it's called live photos
because you can adjust the amount of
blur you have in the background and see
the effect in the viewfinder live which
is pretty cool you take the photo and
then you can adjust the amount of blur
after the photo is taken and it also
takes a simultaneous photo with the main
camera just in case that portrait one
isn't good enough so we're doing a lot
with that second camera you may or may
not find it useful you may never even
use it but the fact that it's there and
it works well alongside one of the best
main cameras in any smartphone means it
definitely checks that box and then with
performance this thing is a monster it
has some high end some might say
best-in-class hardware on the inside
Snapdragon 835 Adreno 546 gigs of ram
and it moves through Samsung's skin just
fine that's not quite - the smoothness
level of phones that are much closer to
stock Android I feel the need to mention
this like I noticed that mostly when
scrolling through a lot of big heavy
stuff or through multitasking especially
it's not quite as
fast but it's not really a big enough
deal to be a bad thing like it's just a
tiny delay I noticed because I use a lot
of other phones but gaming and moving
through apps and web browsing and all
that other stuff has no problems on this
phone but that doesn't mean I can't wish
for a Google Play edition like old times
so as you probably expect from a
flagship that has these kind of specs
inside it checks the performance box too
so then we get to battery life and
that's the one box I can't say Galaxy
Note 8 checks it does not have great
battery life this phone has a 3300
milliamp hour battery which would
ordinarily sound like a pretty solid
size but then you consider your packing
like the world's brightest 6.3 inch
smartphone display and then it starts to
sound a little bit lacking for
perspective the galaxy s 8 plus has a
smaller display but has a larger 3500
milliamp hour battery so for that it has
much better battery life so first of all
the note has an entire column in the
side of it that you have to use for the
stylus so you can't fit battery in there
and then also the fact that they kind of
don't want to push the battery to the
limits on the note because of what
happened last time they tried that that
kind of explains why it's a 3300
milliamp hour battery in this one so
with this phone you kind of have to play
the battery life versus a resolution
game out the box you're gonna get this
preset which is in the middle you're
scaling down the resolution a bit so
it's kind of like they know you're not
going to get the best battery life and
that right off the bat is gonna get you
a little bit less than 4 hours of screen
on time at least with my types of usage
when you turn the resolution further
down you can definitely ensure you get
to a full day but that's a little bit
less enjoyable and when you max out the
resolution which they kind of don't want
you to do unless you turn on performance
mode which is the mode that maxes the
brightness and resolution you're gonna
get less than 4 hours for sure you're
gonna get 3 and a half hours of screen
on time and you'll probably have to
top-up the battery at some point during
the day so that's a pretty unfortunate
stat the Galaxy Note used to be that
phone that power users get because of
the battery life I remember back in the
early days of the Galaxy Note at CES
like all the youtubers took this phone
to CES because it checked all the boxes
it had a huge screen and it lasted
forever this is just not that same phone
it does not check the box of great
battery life now all that being said
there is still the point that I made at
the beginning of the video which is the
note kind of adds this sixth category of
the extras and from using this phone
it's pretty clear that this is still the
phone to buy because of the extras is
these little things that this phone has
that others simply don't it's the iris
scanner if you're into that for
unlocking your phone with just your eyes
it's the expandable storage via a micro
SD if you have a big media library or
take a lot of photos and videos it's the
headphone jack yeah that's that's become
a thing many phones don't have now the
full water-resistance the dual cameras
and all their features the Bluetooth 5.0
with dual audio and everything that
comes with that and the s-pen which I'd
say is the best stylus experience in any
phone right now for people who take a
lot of notes or write a lot of things
down so these are things that separate
the note 8 in a little way from other
phones and give people that unique
reason to buy it as a matter of fact it
seems like the only phone this one
doesn't really separate itself from what
those extras is Samsung's own Galaxy S 8
plus which has all of those things
except for the dual cameras and the
stylus and the difference between them
is about 150 bucks so that really is the
biggest challenge when you consider all
the boxes you want to have checked isn't
worth the extra money to get a phone
that also has the dual cameras and a
stylus but maybe doesn't have quite as
good of a battery life especially when
you consider the galaxy s 8 plus cost
less so if you're like me and you just
want the best possible most complete
phone then Galaxy Note 8 is definitely
still to buy and you kind of just have
to deal with the intermittent charging
up during the day but you still have
really fast fast charging and wireless
charging so if that's available to you
it's not a big deal but also consider
galaxy si plus delivers a really really
similar experience checks one extra box
with good battery and cost a bit less
money so that's a consideration if
you're looking to save a few bucks
so that's pretty much it thank you for
watching talked to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]